hello i'm matthias and the founder
of datatec in this video i'll explain to
you in a simple way what the key
square test is and how you can calculate the key
square test online in just a few steps
this brings us
straight to the first question what is the
war square  is the square test is
a hypothesis test that
is used when you want to determine is whether
there is a connection between two
categorical variables if there
are categorical variables again
categorical variables are, for example,
gender with the characteristics
male female or the preferred
newspaper bild faz  handelsblatt or the
frequency of television daily
several times a week
zeltner never or e.g. the highest
educational qualification all of this in
categorical variables no
categorical variables are for
example a person’s weight a person’s
salary or electricity consumption
so whenever we have two
categorical variables where
we  want to check whether there is
a connection let's use the
square key only for example might
interest us is there a
connection between gender and the
preferred newspaper
or is there a connection
between gender and the frequency of
television viewing or is there
a connection between the preferred one
newspaper and the frequency of
television or the last example, there
is a connection between the
frequency of television and the
highest level of education a person has,
so whenever we have two categorical
variables, use one categorical
variable on the one hand and one
categorical variable on the other
hand  let's do a square
test say we want to find out
whether gender has an influence on the
highest educational
qualification our question would be then there is
a connection between gender and
the highest educational qualification for this
we create a kl  a questionnaire
that we left out as many people as possible
so we simply ask the person
their gender and the highest level of
education
we have the result of the survey displayed
in this excel spreadsheet in
this table
each row is a respondent, i.e. the
first respondent is  male and
has the highest secondary
school leaving certificate the second
person interviewed is female and has the highest
secondary school
leaving certificate we can now use this table and copy it in
a statistical software that datatec
datatec then first gives us
a cross table this
table lists the variable
gender  and highest
educational qualification and we
can read how often a combination
occurs, for example without qualification and
female appears exactly six times in this table
or without qualification and
male appears exactly seven times in this table
but now we want to
know whether the gesc  bad has an influence
on the highest educational qualification so
does it have an influence whether i am female
or male in relation to the
highest educational qualification i have
or in other words there is
a connection between gender and
the highest educational
qualification to answer this question
we need the  square fixed now there are two
ways how we can calculate the square is
either we
use statistics software like datatec or
we calculate the squares by hand we
start with the
uncomplicated variant and
use data tab for this simply search for data
tab on google or  enter date up
de in your
browser now click on the statistics calculator
now you will see a table here in which
you
can copy your own data before you copy your own data in
please teach this table
first i have prepared this data once
you can do this now  just
copy and into data ei  add
like this and now we simply copy this data
into a data tab
please make sure that the variable
names are in the first row
here if you have copied the data here
then the variable names appear here
because the values ​​of the variables are
words he recognizes  app automatically
that
the variables are nominal. For example,
the gender is coded with 0 and 1.
If the offender type would assume that it
was a metric, then
you would have to click once on the variable view
and for the gender variable, set
the even level to nominal  change so
we want a square it calculates
so let's just click here on
square test next we want to
evaluate the variables gender and at most the educational level
so we just gender and at most
the educational level from now
we already get the results for
the square down here is here  get the
cross table with the observed
freq  things we have the variable
gender and highest level of
education and how the
respective combination
occurs female and no qualification occurs six
times here below we see the
crosstabulation of what it would look like if
the two variables became perfectly
independent if there was no
connection between gender and the  there is the highest level of
education
the cross table would actually look like this the square
compare this table with this
table and we can see the results
here below 10 in this case a
ph value of 0.9 18 house so we
'll be pretty happy
because we set the significance level to 0
.05, this value is of
course much larger than the
specified significance level and 0
hypothesis is thus maintained, so in
our case it comes out there is
no connection between im gender and
the highest educational qualification data
offers which also offers an interpretation
in words you just need
together  version in words click here
and can now easily
read the result
a square test was performed between
gender and at most the
educational level no
expected cell counts were
less than five there was no
statistically significant
relationship between gender and at most the level of
education and here we see
then  once the results so
either you look at this practical
interpretation
or you just go down here in the
table and the svp repels so and
now let's take a closer look at the result
we used data tab
to calculate the square
in addition, we have set a significant
level of 5 percent, which
means that again,
this means that if the p values ​​are
less than 0.05, the
prosthesis is rejected, but we got
a ph value of 0 91 8.
this value is of course around  somewhat
greater than the significance niv  eau of
0.05 therefore in our case
there is no connection between
gender and highest
educational qualification and you can calculate a square
online with data p easily
and now i will show you
how you can calculate the square test by hand
for this we need
the cross table  With the
observed frequencies and the
cross table with
the expected frequencies, we get the expected frequencies
by
looking at what this table would
look like with perfectly independent
variables, i.e. if gender had
no influence on the highest
educational
qualification, how should the survey actually end, i.e. us
once the observed frequency
and once the expected frequency have the
squared value, we can now
calculate using the following formula where k is the
observed frequency of a
cell and ek is the expected frequency
of a cell
if we now apply this formula to our
example  n
where we calculate the observed frequency
6 - the expected frequency of 6.08
squared by the expected
frequency of 6.08 just the next
zelda 7 - 6.92 by the expected
frequency of 6.02 now let's do this
for each  more cells and add up the
result we hope we get a
squared value of 0 5 0 4
so once we have the calculated
we also need the
degrees of freedom the degrees of freedom
result from the number of rhine
- 1 times the  number of columns - once
the number of rhine is three the
number of columns is 2 so
we get 1 out of three and we keep
degrees of freedom 3 now we can read the critical square value from this table
we have chosen the significance level of
0.05  and have
degrees of freedom of 3 so we get the critical square value 7815 by the way you can use this table on
data traffic so the critical square
wi  rd in our case of 7.8 15
so our calculated squared value of 0
5 0 4 is
smaller than the critical squared value
this means that the new hypothesis is
retained
so we now come to the same
result as before with the ipad app of
course a little  cumbersome and
so now you know what the key square
test is and how you can easily
calculate it online if you don't know data tab
just google for data tab
on datatec if it's so great tutorials
and you can evaluate your data online in no time at all
if you provide information
as soon as a new video comes out from me
just subscribe to this channel and
press the bell have fun